[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
red this week at the round table of dim
lighting it's an AMA podcast you sent us
questions about anything and everything
and we've selected some of our faves
that's SAV s short for favorites for
those of you who heard don't know that
which there is one person out there just
so you know there's always one person
who and you know what you cleared it up
for yeah right
it's a guy Philly a guy you cleared it
up definitely a guy um the first
question because we're gonna get right
into this comes from me because right
before we started recording my question
was my statement to the people who were
in the room as I scanned the room not
including you was you guys you're too
young to see you're gonna go there again
yeah I thought you just did that but
that was a pre podcast thing and I'm
gonna bring it up I think it's worth
bringing up because I just know what I
need some camaraderie here cuz you
didn't back me up I'm not a communist
I have hid there was a time in my life
where I had a television that in order
to make it work you had to hit the side
of it and it worked because we were
trying to get this headphone thing
working and I told Meggie just to hit it
or blow in it like a cartridge in that
does it does work and it is working now
it is working now she did not hit it
like a television but there may come a
time during this podcast in which it
doesn't work at that point I'm going
naked that's shorthand for saying I'm
taking my headphones off only and I feel
like I could do the home so glad that's
all that Nick without them I feel like
it's a crutch I feel like the headphones
are a crutch for a bad hair day you know
it explains why the the backside here
hairdo is so flattened yeah second
question is from Kendall Sanders or
Sanders if I recall correctly Kendall
had lots of good questions I think we've
narrowed it down to this one if we were
to switch bodies a la Freaky Friday
what is a quark you think you may need
to tell me about your body that I should
be aware of hmm and I she wrote it as if
I was asking you so this is me asking
you if if I switch to your body what
would you need to tell me about it and
vice versa and then she goes on for
example some of mine would be my knees
always cracked it's nothing to be
concerned about I have a small cowlick
in the right side of my head you'll
never tame if your ankles start to hurt
just pop the toes and you'll instantly
feel better that's if you go into
Kendall's body I love this come Kendall
I love this question because pops are
pops our toes and our ankles feel better
yeah only Kendall knows that and could
you imagine if you switched with Kendall
and you had crazy ankles for three weeks
but you need to know you just had to pop
the toes and you couldn't talk to
Kendall because that would be you yeah
so first of all before great question
bodies before you switch bodies with me
we would need like a week-long class I
mean I am a very I mean what give me the
truncated version here because what if
it happens as a result of something we
discuss or if we hit the invisible
trigger I don't know I didn't watch a
few Freaky Friday yeah I missed that one
well first of all just being a large
person you know someone who's six foot
seven who's about an inch shorter than
your typical doorframe Oh with hair
grazing the doorframe there's a whole
like doorframe conversation which is
just when in doubt duck which is you're
always in doubt so you should always
duck a little bit while indoors so just
walk around hunch always be hunched in
high school you did have a you did have
a little bit of a hunch yes for the
doorframes hey I have since corrected my
posture for the most part mostly due to
like yoga and Pilates etc but there's
there's this de body size thing but
there's also like if you if you're
trying to bike up a hill your right
knees gonna start hurting if you're
trying to just walk down a hill your
right knees gonna start hurting and you
and you really I I wasn't tracking with
what you're saying for a second I didn't
know you'd moved on to other things I
thought you were still talking about
moved your hike going through a door
so I thought you were presenting an
analogy it's you know if you if you bike
up a hill you're right and he's gonna
stop hurting in the st. you start
hurting the same way you have to Doug
knew it there's our new stuff you've
moved on okay so I'm I should listen if
I'm gonna if I'm gonna become you I can
your right knee yeah I can get little
fellows out with my tongue I knew that
that that's a good reason to become you
because hey I don't have tonsils anymore
to have the tonsil stones in them and
it's so annoying being on the receiving
end of like you making that face and I
can tell you're digging your tongue and
I don't know here so I don't evil out up
pustule I don't even get him anymore
when's the last time you saw me make
that face it's been years that's true
the reason is because I got so adept at
just getting stuff out the moment that
it's in the tassels that it's almost
just like a knee it's a completely I
don't stuff consciousness this is part
of your eating regimen you just you just
let your constant I clean my tonsils you
lick your tonsils yeah see and you know
you your biscuit ear are feeling the
same way I feel which is this is gross
why are you talking about this important
information if you're gonna take over my
body but I do I am curious when I do
become you and I experience it from the
inside out if I will get it
oh I understand why no matter how much I
tell them and it annoys me or how gross
it is to anyone including everybody
listening that it's now worth it I know
that it's worth it yeah is that what
you're telling me well I'm just also
saying when you turn your head to the
left you're gonna do that you're gonna
feel for pops completely normal happens
every time you're gonna have a recurring
pain in the upper back a recurring pain
in the middle back and a recurring pain
in the lower back but if you get up and
do a series of stretches which I can
give you diagrams every single morning
preferably with your dog on your face
the whole time you will you will gain
mastery over these things also every
once in a while just while breathing
you're going to feel a sharp pain right
in the middle of chest you're going to
think that you're having a heart attack
it is not a heart attack it is also not
a pinched lung as link would call it
yeah pinched lung because paint
don't have nerves it's just a spasm of
sorts in your rather impressive pectoral
muscles I will say that um let's see
what else can you follow on Instagram I
mean that's probably that's just day one
I could go on I won't because this is an
unlikely scenario but I'm just saying I
got a lot I got a lot I can tell you
what about you when you enter my body
and become me that's kind of a weird way
to put it I would say just enjoy it man
it's pretty good
the water's fine you don't have any
light precautions like don't touch sharp
objects I mean like no I would at least
say that just live with and sleep with
reckless abandon you know it's the world
is your oyster man just crack it crack
it drop some Tabasco on it and slurp it
down just enjoy it because it won't last
forever but it will change you forever
yeah you'll be you well you're pretty
big when you change back to you you will
still have lasting effects of swimming
in the ocean of link oh gosh let's move
on to the next question you I could go
on please don't
we'll both write manuals my will be in
Gerda's not at all here's your's a
guided tour this is not helpful TAFE
Andrews ask do you have a paramedic on
set well that's a good question
so as we're filming good mythical
morning do we have a paramedic action
yes and that is a recent addition yes
and on any given day we have a rotation
of paramedics it's not the same one
every day I don't think they can they
can handle the suspense but this is me
almost chopping your fingers off but
this is a slow build I will say hello in
your face off of something backs and
then if you go back to basics they go
back to the first few years of GMM there
was nothing if we
if we had I was your paramedic accident
you were my paramedic if someone was
going to die and and then that turned
into some time like 18 months ago well
there was a middle point where we would
if we like one of the first person we
people were hired we were looking for an
editor and so we were looking for an
editor slash CPR registered babysitter I
think it's we didn't say that but that's
kind of I don't recall that we were
looking at resumes it's like we knew we
needed a lot but I do seriously remember
about 18 months ago Stevie was like well
several people on the crew are now CPR
certified it's like good idea and then
in November well give them something to
practice on when GM became a youtube
original and we were able to get some
more resources one of the resources that
we got was a budget that allowed us to
have a full-time paramedic and the funny
thing is is regardless of who it is it's
I look over there and I see her face
from I'm like a hawk it's it's never a
relaxed face yeah it's always like this
you can hit the fan real quick here I
just I don't you know what maybe I'll
own some of this I don't get the
impression from the paramedics that I
put them at ease no you don't I just get
that vague impression hey they're
looking at me a lot are you looking at
you most of the time this is true I mean
there was a recent there was a recent
thing that we filmed that I'm not gonna
describe because it's it's not out yet
it's like a special thing it may never
come out by the way depending on how the
thing before it goes when it comes out
oh that thing so because we filmed your
thing then we phoned my thing right
afterwards even though we wanted to
introduce space in between them for you
to have some time to digest one before
the next and when I was I I thought it
was a near-death experience like the
point was I wasn't supposed to say
anything there was like a conceit to
this video I'm sorry I can't give you
details but I thought you were acting I
was not acting but I was staying in
character
huh you think about that no I wanted to
stay within the rule the the rules of
the of the piece but I'd I was very
afraid I thought I should release it no
matter what the reaction to my thing is
okay especially now that I've talked
about it without talking about it but I
look at when I was done I look I walked
out and I was okay by that point I was
still in pain but I was okay and I knew
I wasn't gonna die and I went by I can't
remember which paramedic it was kind of
all blurs together anyway she she was
she was I was like what would you have
done and she was like well I was
thinking about that but III didn't reach
any conclusion so she she was there she
was thinking it through like oh I'm the
one but I don't know how to deal with
this specific thing but I mean we can't
really keep talking about unless you
want to say what it was because well
there's certain things that you're
choking on that there's nothing you can
do the Heimlich doesn't work for certain
yes that you're choking on we'll leave
it at s and we'll get back to these
questions in one second but we will stop
very briefly to let you know that you
know what you can get I actually wore
tell me on the podcast recently yes
cotton-candy Randi t-shirts yeah it says
hi daddy's which is cotton candy Randy's
favorite thing to say and when you put
the shirt on it whispers disturbing
secrets in your ear
cotton candy Randy is my favorite person
and a lot of people think that it's just
a character played by Jordan one of our
writers but actually it he's real it's
just a real I don't wanna say superhero
but fictional purse a real fictional
he's a caring person he is a fake person
played by Jordan is that what you know
he's like the Easter Bunny he's a real
fictional person right he's not just one
of our writers he's like he's a cultural
phenomenon and a lot of people really
first of all cotton candy Randy is
polarizing and polarizing things are my
favorite things that polarizing things
are great on t-shirts yeah and so if you
hate cotton
dear Annie that's why I love cotton
candy Randy and if because if that's why
my buddy doesn't you buy it it's not
worth loving if somebody doesn't hate it
it's not worth loving that's how I feel
about it because if everybody's just
looking at me like I'm it so it's pretty
good then it's not it's not great
somebody's gotta hate it some people
hate cotton candy ready I will say so
great the haters should go to mythical
dot store and buy the cotton candy rainy
t-shirt because they can burn it you're
buying the right to deface it yeah you
can do whatever it's not like and money
here you can buy our merchants astray it
right support internat Ament rep your
teams you can get that at both mythical
store but you can also get it amazon.com
slash mythical our amazon store check
out both of those stores because they
have different stuff except for that
which has both of them yeah yeah it's
your turn to ask a question well then
let me ask it this one's from Katherine
is I birth yes I've always wanted to
know what your wives think about your
jobs there's an exclamation point I
didn't anticipate it
especially when you dress up like women
well that's cry laugh emoji well should
I include emojis and when I ask the
question yeah the part about dressing up
like women does not blip their radar no
so we do that at home most times I'm not
doing it I'm just not digging into that
one because it's a if that's it's just a
non-issue yeah they're committing kids
or what nor wives are ever surprised by
what we may wear come home smelling like
it's just all a big blur at this point
now you know Christie Norma kids watch
every episode of good mythical morning
they do you know I come home and and
it's like they live with that's the show
right that is the show no it's like I
don't know I don't think I'd want to
watch somebody that I lived with watch
their show every single day but then
they do like it and they do like to
catch up on parts of it but so Christie
doesn't watch that much or or listen at
your busiest and
Oh today I got a text from Christie I'm
pulling it up just a few hours ago she
texted me you don't believe in a soul
mate which was our last ear biscuit
conversation did I say you know what
happened somebody out wasn't she never
listen listen to our podcast what
happened is somebody who knows them
listen to our podcast and then it was
like knows our wives and then you think
Jessie might have gotten I bet you when
I get home tonight I'm gonna get it she
ain't gonna text me I don't know did you
say so wait till I get home did you
she's gonna ambush I said the same thing
but she knows this is how I feel already
she knows that in fact I think the fact
that she knows that that's how I feel
makes our love even more special right
honey
well let's pause on that for a second
this is what I responded to Christy haha
I was telling you about this oh gosh oh
really that's your response I think I
was haha I think I did I'm pretty sure
that I had mentioned to her that this
has come up on an ear biscuit oh but it
hasn't come up at a personal
conversation before you before um not in
in recent years no it's not just it's
not like dinner talk for us
hey let's bring up that are we soul
mates conversation again but I I saw you
soul mates is is there such thing as
soul I know such and then she responded
I don't remember and of course I can't
tell if there's sarcasm in that I don't
know I haven't talked to and I was like
yeah and I love you and I actually do
think you are my soul mate
smiley face it's our special secret oh
gosh what what and you laughed at that
and then she says nope
that secret needs to be made public oh
well it has been now and I responded
winky-face emoji oh it's almost like
you're in a different conversation yeah
yeah well first of all that's not a
winky face emoji that's a semicolon and
a parenthesis do you know man how it's
done
oh there's a whole keyboard for it I
also hit television is to get them to
function you usually think that it will
automatically translate into an emoji if
you do it right I didn't but maybe maybe
that is a successful distraction
technique the biggest revelation in this
whole exchanges that you're still doing
in the semicolon in the parenthesis
honestly on phone in an email it's one
thing I'm certain I'll talk to her about
it but she does not listen his podcast
and we have a rat who is the rat it
could be my sister-in-law it could be
your brother-in-law yep there's a number
of people well that's the only two I can
think of your sister listens to this
yeah I recently found out my brother's
wife oh yes she likes to listen to it
while she does things oh gosh she's
listening right now we're making it
worse you know what you've done it
you've done a plenty as we would say
you've done a plenty you who know who
you are
I like rats many people have rats but in
general our wives really love our show
is that when we say things like there
are no such thing as soul mates I'm
certain that I've talked to Christi
about her not being my soul mate any
more than any if I almost texted back I
was like yeah no but you put you're
still putting it wrong you don't say
you're not my soul mate you me like I
don't believe in the concept no one held
oats yeah and you know you'd be wrong
you know I've sold my mind you can
become a soul mate this is much easier
this way I was wrong I am really sorry
Christy is my soul mate
I'm her soul mate I don't know about
anybody else yep and Jesse's my soul
mate too right solved Katie and bling
Barsky
yes how do your kids handle you guys
being famous I'm not sure if you'd like
that to be the word I use but you
understand no you can say it since they
go to school and everyone is on the
internet do they love it hate it do all
their friends watch you guys this is a
great question Katie Ann because I think
that our kids do have opinions about
this yeah they do
I mean Lilly's 14 Locke is 13 Lincoln is
12
Shep got a shepherd nine nine and then
Lando is seven and they're all about to
increment up a year many of them
everyone except Shep will turn a new
year in the next 12 and Alexa for 20 30
days how many numbers can you say wrong
I don't know well for Twitty right none
of those were prime numbers though
that's I'm proud of that
well I know I know your your your eldest
lock has been more concerned about it
than Lily which surprised me a little
bit Lily going to a new school and all I
mean my interpretation is that Locke
wants to be his own person wants to
establish his own deal doesn't want to
be first and foremost known as my son
and you never get a first chance to make
a second impression yep and there are
there are situations like there have
been some things like there was an event
at his school that was like some sort of
like pancake breakfast or something and
this is like what he had been going to
school for like a week or two and you
know he was new to school because they
have been homeschooled he was like I
don't want you to come to that because
if I go to something that with kids in
that age group it can you know it's the
pictures start and and it just becomes
about me being there and you know so you
and me I knew why yeah and I'm like cool
I don't want to go anyway no but so I
get out a lot of things because no but I
totally get it
and and then we had like there was like
an event like a knock
hilber fest event that his some of his
friends were going to but we were also
gonna go to it and he was like I don't
want to walk around with you you know
and I and I get it I totally get it and
I and I actually went to that thing or
something very similar to it with
Lincoln he's a great lower at the same
school and yeah there was those moments
there was like some picture opportunity
moments and there was just a risk there
of like is it was this you know how's
that gonna Lincoln wasn't too fazed by
it but I don't like it what happens at
one of his things yeah yeah like a
sporting event or something like that
right like the team that you just played
wants the kids from that team want to
come get a picture of me I'm just like
yeah but I don't wanna be a jerk to
those kids and be like no yeah that's
happened to me too but so i Lincoln's
opponents are taking pictures with me
it's like that's there's a loyalty thing
happening here right yeah I don't I
don't take pictures with the the enemy
but I mean I went to Lando's grade
school for some event and he was like so
excited to have me there and then there
were a few like with those younger kids
even a few picture moments happening and
like he would just went away he went
somewhere else he did not want to stay
right there
I mean he's Elena's pretty shy you know
so it he definitely would never see that
as an opportunity hey hey hey you know
like I probably would have when I was
his age Shepard does Owen Sheppard
because we were talking about this right
when they were starting school I figured
that the word would get around mm-hmm
and was we were just talking about did
like I think if kids come up and I asked
you is your dad on the internet or
whatever and that was like yeah I kind
of say and he kind of took the
approaches like sometimes I just say no
like I don't know what you're talking
about
because I don't want to have a
conversation about it but Shepherd the
shepherd was like I told my class all
day one my dad's on YouTube like 30
great Mandy not and just telling
everybody in class now I mean when we
were first talking about that with
Lincoln I was like Lincoln does this
concern you and he was like yeah like
you know we both have discussed being it
you know helping our kids be a good
judge of character that
their friends want to be there they're
friends and not just yeah proxy our
friends through our kids there's you
know just think it's cool to be
associate you all gonna be friends
because of them and then Lincoln comes
home a few days a few days later he's
like honey can I get your autograph I
want to give it to a friend like weren't
you listening
as far as 2018 autographs are not a
thing
signature is that what we call them now
they don't happen no I'm um saying but
it gets difficult because there's a
fundraiser at Lando school he loves his
school and then a teacher asked me if I
would show up to be one of the prizes
for the kids that raise the most money
well how like just to come out of a meet
and greet situation okay and potentially
both of us but you know I knew I knew
how sensitive Lando was and it's a hard
thing to say no to when it's like you
just feel like they're not gonna
understand why you're saying no but this
would really impact how the school
viewed Lando potentially and you know
there's there's enough things that he's
trying to figure out how the other kids
how the other kids what did I say that's
cool I mean yeah all the kids in the
school yeah would start to see him and
it's a you don't want to be defined by
somebody else yeah or something else
that's not you in general I don't think
it it's but it was a hard thing to say
no to it was it was easy that that was
the right choice for us but it was you
just you know when you feel like you
can't you try to explain why but it's
you know it's frustrating for the person
planning cuz they had a good idea in
their mind and then you're like well now
you practically now you got to start
over
right yeah and I might be a jerk I don't
know
give me another question actually my
turn I got a made you've got some
questions now
Minerva lgp asks do you play any bets
between the two of you it looks like you
were very much into games and
competition on GMM does that happen
often
IRL that's good mythical morning versus
in real life
both acronyms yeah this is actually
something that we've done for a long
time going back to when we were kids yes
most of the time it's like if I can hit
that rock if I can hit that pole with
this rock you gotta give me $5 that was
the beauty of childhood the way that we
worked man we were just like just like
coyotes on the prowl around Buies Creek
just had all the time in the world to do
whatever we wanted and when he just
mosey sometimes you just mosey and like
down the street pushing your bike or
whatever and riding the many many many
times I would say ninety eight ninety
five percent of the time you and you
would instigate some sort of pseudo
athletic prowess bet that's what life's
all about
you know it's like throwing this you
know this is this was pre dude perfect
we were still hitting televisions to
make them work yep but it was you know
can you throw this rock over the power
line but then get it through the hoop in
my basketball goal as I'm entering the
door to get a KitKat from the cabinet it
doesn't have to be that intricate but
but then we would sit there we had we
had time to mosey here since every 20
minutes trying a beautiful thing about
this is that you can take what otherwise
is just a completely boring moment in
life and yet you have an object in an
environment you can create a challenge
that can get a group of people so fired
up like and I absolutely love to do this
you know if it's if it's comedic ly
frivolous enough then I'll also get
involved but the competition aspect of
it doesn't resonate with me but the the
sheer nuts factor is what I was because
here's what here's the beautiful thing
so like so it's not about winning money
not too long ago who's never really I
mean we always say no but nobody ever
gets paid but I'm her friend Mike Mike
was featured in the quest for the the
perfect taco on our Instagram story yeah
from oh yeah so Mike was out here and we
were a
my basketball goal in my house and we
were some I likes it was like alright
I'm gonna see if I can throw it up on
top of the house two-story house have it
bounce off of the Spanish tile roof so
it big which is not a predictable bounce
no it's not at all come back down and go
into the hoop and we're talking about
horse here this was anyway a horse cuz
no one can actually we played a game of
horse but then we just started trying
this shot and and then it we quickly
learn the chances of this going in are
so slim that if it does go in we're
gonna go nuts and so just one after
another the three of us just like
rotating kept doing it and and it never
once did you think we should film this
and no send it to Texas but when it
happened it did happen did I hit it I
made it you did how long did it take at
12 minutes you know I mean we're
shooting a lot so it felt more
impossible than it was yeah but when it
happened the celebration the the
embraces the jumping in the air yeah the
yelling yeah you would think that
someone had won something significant
but no we just created a little
challenge or had like it a child just
the other day when we were we were
shooting the dude perfect parity thing
the bill goes the field goals kicks um
we've got yeah we got done and I was
like I'm gonna throw this football to
that trashcan
yeah from a from a distance that any
middle school quarterback it was like 20
yards and I threw it like 20 times in
now eventually I got hold what you threw
once then I threw it and when I threw it
I almost hit it yeah right off the bat
yeah but neither of us made it it never
all my shoulder got hurt and then the
paramedic had to come over exactly like
two throws in link sitting down getting
massages from the paramedic the only the
only useful thing the paramedic has done
the whole time that we've been employed
no she's given us a sense of veneer of
safety well she is very useful that
she's there I'm just unsure inspire jit
yeah those are two big things and then
the third thing the most work when my
shoulder got tweaked in the quarterback
zone quarterback zone she
ahand it wasn't when you say getting a
massage from the massage lasted 20
minutes I was like when is Lee gonna get
back into this Wow
I lost heart man I didn't even I didn't
even get it get it in there because I
lost heart cuz you just got a massage
but Andrew the cameraman started tossing
it yeah but nobody did not the same as
me huh I know you can say it it wasn't
the same that's it anyway shoulders
still hurt I think it's a great way to
inject some stakes I think our life a
hereditary shoulder issue I went to
therapy a few years back that's what got
me back into the gym to maintain the
ground I regained from physical therapy
in this joint my shoulder but my dad he
came he picked me up from college one
day and he took me on Christmas shopping
to buy my gifts cuz that's what that was
our tradition and we were having a good
old time and in the Crabtree Valley Mall
and I just I'll just leaned over and I
just I just punched him on the shoulder
just like a look we caught what we call
a love lick my granddad would always
pinch me or give you a twister in the
tea region or like just a good wallop on
the arm or a frog on the leg that's a
lovely so I gave my dad one of those
that's just a way to non-verbally say I
love you and I'm powerful and my dad
didn't tell me for like six months but I
severely damaged his shoulder like he
said he it started hurting something he
he had to go to the doctor and it and
like the ligament had separated oh
you're such a jerk I'm sad I felt
horrible and you didn't tell me for six
months and now I think I'm getting it so
I'm literally telling my kids like don't
know love licks in the shoulders you
know there's you know how you know how
broad they are they're so usually that
means they're not susceptible as
susceptible to I mean they're really far
apart and not in a good way and like a
and like a disproportionate robot yeah
it's like kind of like sideview mirrors
that are just waiting to be
clipped by another car and then the
collarbones are so prominent yeah
there's something just anatomically is
not correct about my shoulder reader
wear shoulder pads all the time like my
mom in the 80s and the 90s you could
bring me only 2000 US backed where I
could just go raid her closet for all of
her trench coats
I'd be like Kevin Smith but with more
shoulder pads let's ask another question
ask one Laurel Ann browning as lifelong
best friends have you ever had the
conversation if I die first I want to
dot dot dot ooh let's get into death if
I die first I want to dot dot dot have
we had this conversation she wants to
know well we did have the like tactical
logistical conversation just about like
because we had to like create our like
in the whole insurance deal you know
like a couple years ago and we yeah went
through the whole process of like
creating wills and insurance and and
that kind of thing but none of that
really answers the question well because
I mean it turns out if you have if you
have a successful business as a duo I
mean that where you're kind of the faces
of this thing well it was pointed out to
us you have you I mean we had to explore
all this stuff that literally included
like if one of us dies like what happens
I mean because you have this catalog of
videos that you know I mean face it when
one of us dies a lot of you will watch a
lot of them even more so than or being
watched now so there's that generates
income and so it's like well how do you
distribute it if I die well I get I get
all the money no because I got it with a
family that's what my contracts know so
it was like vice by first and it's like
both it's like when they say that like
Taylor Swift has her legs insured which
I don't know if that's an urban legend
or it's true but basically Mary Hart
they just updated the urban legend do
the duo is insured right so when the duo
is no longer a duo because the
the untimely death of one of the duo's
one part of the duo it's really our
wives we the other person's wife will be
well taken care of and there'll be
there's an insurance payment which
basically though so like let's say I die
good then not your figuring not know I
don't mean good I mean if one of us is
if we're gonna say one of us it's good
that you chose you know and so then you
have to kind of figure out what what are
you gonna do right what why what's next
for the linkster yes identity that's
much bigger question I do think you
should begin to refer to yourself as the
link at that point because you just go
right what I found is that with the
exception of share you can't just have a
one syllable name and just be known by
that link you got Oprah 2-shot Madonna
you got to go to the linkster with it
with a V that's my first piece of advice
but also I already knew that you will
get paid an insurance payment which is
the whole link transforming into the
linkster
transition period where you're figuring
out what you're gonna do and what is the
link is gonna be known for is you gonna
are you gonna learn to juggle
I suggest that as well yeah you can take
you to leave it all these ideas alright
there'll be quite a bit of floundering
and the floundering will be covered by
an insurance plan and by that I
literally mean fishing for flatfish the
linkster
whose eyes wandering right your oceans
gonna be you're gonna be like a building
sabbatical what was a bill dance yeah I
was watching bill dance you know there's
a there's a reddit montage yes dance
dance is that his name bill dance like
I'm verify that police fishermen bill
dance
he had a fishing show and I think he
still does anywheres at Texas hat
Tennessee Tennessee oh I'm sorry
oh gosh you just ascended so many I know
I'm just out an orange team I'm out of
her orange long horn its tennis we just
lost a lot of fans there God now I'm
just talking to you because that's all
we had yes I just I mean it's kind of
Winnebago ish but it's build Nance
talking to the camera while he's fishing
and then all types of stuff happens he's
the greatest no you're the Winnebago Man
as the
oh no they're all they're both great
they're both great right why don't
always forget that
but anyway so with that second cure
worst runner in the history of good
mythical morning but it always has to be
reestablished Andrea explain us of what
it is that's not common but it's a
legitimate question
so I mean oh we're having the
conversation now I mean links gonna
potentially be a fisherman but they're
saying if I die well I what Laura want
to know was what our funeral plans are
which we you know we we specified a lot
of those in the book so we won't go
through that book all the callee and
that does lead into a tandem question
which faith shoe craft will you be
buried next to each other yeah so if we
die together
you know that's simple you know we know
how the money split to the to the
families and you don't have to worry
about floundering right but so but
before we answer we would be buried next
to each other so I think that it's not
you are you gonna you teasing that it's
not like yeah yeah I like the tease when
I can i it's not like well you would go
back to be an engineer I would go back
to be an engineer just because we have
to we would obviously continue on in
some sort of internet a maintainer
squares of light do we need to do should
we replace the person or should we just
be a solo act
like you know I these are these are all
legitimate questions that we would
answer right now whoever is left now we
should that's a cross that bridge when
the person dies did you write and then
again is there's money for floundering
yeah and you never know what kind of you
never know what it's gonna be is this a
death you can see coming from miles away
or is this sudden real real really
interesting not sad at all so wait so
we're pushing that off but if we die at
the same time we'll be what will we be
being or not or not well though buried a
I'm not gonna be buried okay I'm gonna
be cremated be okay
is that news to you well I just once
they ask it I was like man that would be
pretty cool be buried next to you I
guess if I get cremated then dividing
the ashes up is easy but do you you
don't do you have a like a do you have
like a grave site that you can go to
when you
well I thought you just on the shelf
somewhere I have been thinking that I
would be I think in the book we say that
we're gonna be cremated because that led
to like a comedic I've said cremated for
for quite some time but I really like
the idea of biodegrading in a
biodegradable box it is the most
environmentally responsible way and I've
already done it once but you can't be
you can't you can't be you have to be
creepy was yeah he was buried alive in a
cardboard box in in Marshall King pilot
episode of commercial you can't watch
comfort first of all you can watch it on
iTunes commercial Kings is available you
can watch on iTunes or Amazon it's a
show we did like seven years ago on high
of C high that episode it's a good show
my just watch until North Carolina and
we we did a commercial for a company
called bury me naturally and it was a a
woman who Carol Carol Carol motley Carol
motley I remember everything about it
yeah
she sold biodegradable cardboard caskets
and of course if we're gonna make an ad
for it
you had to test it out and Rhett what
you head into breaking up red wouldn't
fit in the friggin cardboard box yeah so
he buried me anyway and you know what
I'd do it all over but I would be dead
yeah being dead would be less nervous
but here's the thing of you know like a
mausoleum
you've got like those drawers if you
just if you take a casket you put it
above ground I'm calling that a
one-person mausoleum take two of those
stack it on top of each other I'm
calling it a two-person mausoleum but
you know what that looks like a GMM desk
then on top of that you put a microphone
you put two but limestone let's make it
limestone you'll be made out of wood
I'll be made out of limestone what about
your wife I'll get to that
whatever our soldiers visages statues
now here's the answer we're not a pretty
I mean you want to have self
aggrandizing isn't it well it wouldn't
be open to the public
I wouldn't charge ticket this isn't a
room somewhere this isn't a there's
somewhere in the woods this isn't a
prize
reserved pasture this isn't the pasture
where we made the blood out maybe it's
like a gorilla reserve I'd be cooling
you have to like get through the
gorillas to get to the statues well it
turns out gorillas are actually very
peaceful spoiler alert but they're very
scary and intimidating most people
gorillas have so the people who know the
truth can just walk right up to the
statues and if you pull on the
microphone it there's audio of something
that we said at some point plenty of
that we can make that right now hello
welcome to the rhett and Link Monument
look to your left
that's gorge the gorilla or a relative
of George you don't know how long George
is gonna be around just name them all
George
that's a footnote yeah they're all named
George he looks pretty intimidating you
had the good sense to walk through the
gorillas knowing that they are naturally
vegetarian and very unlikely to eat you
I can still read for you thanks for
showing up please return your map
to the visitor center okay also down
exit you can also download the app but
it's too late for that because there's
no cell service or whatever they call it
now
in this part of the forest good day
just put your $50 in this box right here
or any any any amount any amount is
accepted over $50 to help keep up the
pristine condition of this monument okay
in recording a side note we're not in
that like our bodies our remains are not
in there no that's why I use the term
monument right right because I'm gonna
be buried my soul my wife my soul mate
but I'm not gonna be buried I'm gonna be
well I am I'm gonna biodegrade I want to
be spread I want my ashes to be spread
50% Pacific Ocean 50% Cape Fear River
you're being real now I am and my wife
knows this but if I decide to go
biodegradable she's gonna have to cut me
in half and I don't know if it's gonna
be like cut me at the waist I think she
should coming down the middle she does
she's not doing any of it she's
instructing people to do this cut me
down the middle because if you get the
top half seems more important well the
bottom half is pretty for it if you come
in most
a horse where it counts you you cut me
down the middle so it's one laterally
one half of my body that part is can you
can't just throw a dead body into the
ocean or the river though no okay if you
got a burnt part of me cut my hands off
burn those bury bury the body mix in my
life put one man charred hand in the
Pacific Ocean you think this is one
charge hand is nothing fun about it man
I was trying to cover my bases so see
she's peasant it's re facetious pheasant
a very active member of the the mythical
community asks a lot of questions link
will you ever return to Instagram at
least post one last picture is that it
that's it man well there's a hashtag
your biscuits but I thought that was
unnecessary last year I was like you
know what I'm really feeling that I
should be on Instagram again but I just
need some incentive to come back and so
I was like what if we did something on
the show and that that would get me back
on Instagram and then we're like yeah we
can people will enjoy that and then come
the top of the year we started we
started filming these segments no I'm
wrong it was earlier than that because
it was at the launch of the expanded GMM
one of the first week so that was that
was in November octo so the idea was in
an October ish anyways it was at that
like the transitional point in the long
story short I just wasn't I wasn't happy
with with the segment well you're the
only one and they're right and it's like
it just didn't nothing was nothing was
how we wouldn't do it like that now and
then of course we did it again because
it was like well maybe we just need you
know we can keep need to do it better I
think I think enough mythical beast care
about me returning the Instagram that
maybe maybe maybe we can just do it
again didn't change enough
and similar happy with it again not
something we would do now in terms of
like the approach in the tone and the
the the well can we talk about that for
just a second before you talk about your
well sure your Instagram because I know
you want to talk about specifically what
your pop well I'm just saying I was
disappointed because I actually thought
that that would lead to me getting back
on Instagram but we're not we're not
doing that segment anymore because I
didn't I didn't like it well and I talk
about it as much as you want to think
it's bigger than that too because I mean
I didn't like it as well but yeah it
seems like the mythical beast didn't
like it because it's interesting you
know I think that we're we said this so
we did our whole podcast where we
defended ourselves against the decision
to change the format of good mythical
morning and I you know I got a little
yeah I was I was offended as you could
tell by the way that I handled myself in
that podcast and from we're offended by
yourself I was offended by myself no no
I'm just saying that like I was I was
struggling with the fact that so many
people were responding the way they
responded responding and making
accusations that they were making about
what we were - while we were doing it
and stuff and you know and then we had
that raw just this is what we're
thinking right now without talking about
it ahead of time podcast which based on
some of the response to that podcast I
was kind of like you know what I kind of
lost my appetite for defending myself
about creative decisions at least for a
while so this isn't in terms of the
process of like how we come on why you
are you prepared to say why that is I
think that I think in general I think it
can be helpful to explain yourself or
why you why you're doing things but it
seems to me that the people who would be
affected by your defense don't really
care for it and the people who would be
affected by your defense don't need it
with rare exception so you know if I
were cuz you know we said ma you but you
don't think that I mean the vast
majority of responses weren't positive
no no I mean like we said before it so
it was kind of helpful to you know to
give window into what
how we were assessing or how
passionately we felt about things I mean
there's a I could have focused more on
the positive things that people were
saying and less on trying to defend
myself against what I thought were
unfair accusations about the reasons why
we were doing what we but it's a it's
just a natural human response to when
you're accused of something to want to
give your perspective but there I mean I
so I think I think we can put in one
pile defending yourself against accusers
is something that you've decided not to
do now but a lot of that podcast for
both of us I think was or both of those
conversations was not coming from a
defensive place but coming from an
explanatory place which is a little bit
different it's like maybe we had
mythical beasts whose heads with who
they're scratching their heads but they
believed they gave us the benefit of the
doubt but there was still doubt or just
gaps so I think it's a different thing
to explaining yourself and defending
yourself right explaining yourself can
all often seem like defending yourself
and I think that sometimes they are the
same thing yeah but all that to say that
you know we tried a lot of things early
on that segment being one of them and a
few other things like that and the way I
would describe that segment was a
scripted segment that took place at the
desk and what we learned very quickly is
that it isn't that people don't want us
to do scripted content right is that
they don't want scripted content to
invade that the non-scripted space which
I call that the desk you know what I'm
saying so it's like doing something that
is obviously written ahead of time at
the desk people don't have an appetite
for that and I totally get that but yeah
if we do a sketch or we do something
where we're playing characters or if we
do something where we're we actually
have a couple things coming out very
soon that it's you know it's more along
the lines of a traditional it's not
really a sketch but you know it's just
written jokes but it's the environment
that we're doing it in is more like it's
not the desk
yeah and it's a shorter video and it's a
more like traditional rhett and Link
you know before GMM sort of internet
video and once we kind of we started to
understand it like oh it isn't that
people don't want us to try to be funny
in different ways it's that they're not
comfortable with us trying this in this
environment but this segment was it one
of those things scripting things at the
desk just ripped the heart out of what
we built at a desk and I think it was
very it was very good to be reminded of
that as a side note and you know that
just kind of gave window into just kind
of the way that we're thinking about the
three videos the yellow border video the
middle one in being as he just said more
of if we remove the constructive
constraints of our show and so now we
can open up to any idea we want that we
want to tag excuse me tackle comedic Lee
we can do it in any way if for the
internet you know and not be not have to
I was gonna say velcro it in but wedge
it or you can Belko it in I don't know a
rough wedge it into where we do our show
but you know back to the Instagram thing
I think it it particularly pinched a
nerve or pinched a nerve because for for
those of you who want me back on
Instagram you legitimately want me back
on Instagram so if we're gonna explore
that on the show I mean you don't want
to toy with it so much that it seems
disingenuous so I think I think that was
that wasn't that was a second strike
against that thing was that we made it
into a comedy bit that yes was scripted
but was also it just it it brought in a
question whether I was actually going to
come back to Instagram at all and the
plan was to come back is the plan still
to come back well it's not gonna be that
way and so now it's like and I do think
I saw a while back that like there was a
there was a buzz that James Hetfield the
lead singer for Metallica after five
years or six years or whatever it was
came back to Instagram and I don't know
what his picture was I was gonna click
on it and then I didn't want to think
about it at that moment so I literally
ran away from the tweet I put my phone
down I ran away
I didn't want to so now I'm back to the
pressure that I that I described it you
know as the premise of the whole bit
which is man you just can't you can you
just sneak in the back door of your of
your of your big party or do you come in
the front door with your sequins on and
say I made it here I am
there's no I mean at this point that
analogy doesn't work because there is
only a front door for you to return to
Instagram through yeah but if I'm just
like if I put like a picture of my
carpet yeah but everyone would see you
it's like walking into a party covered
in a carpet everybody still sees you I
wouldn't be under the car but I do think
that it's it's necessary to james
hetfield it was just a picture of him
holding up he was drinking coffee what
does that say what's the coffee mug say
have a glorious day but then when he
picks it up at somebody flipping the
bird underneath the coffin my middle
finger it's very my real on it in a
metallic or a metallic
well but I think it's important for you
did it was key people to understand too
that your return to Instagram would have
it would be a lot of hoopla around the
first image but then you'd be like me
probably worse than me oh gosh worse in
terms of how often you post I mean I
think I thought you meant promoting
myself on my podcast oh yeah yeah it
would be so much worse than you yeah
yeah but I mean we're both let's just
face it man we're both really bad at
social media like naturally our natural
disposition towards social media is just
really not great I legitimately have hit
the side of a television in order to get
it to work I'm telling you that that
tells you everything you need to know
about why I'm not on Instagram
let's but but I want you to come back I
want you to come back but don't don't
put so much pressure on yourself because
you know that when you come back they're
still gonna be like a month between
pictures and that's okay
I think I should the first one should be
you covered I have a world of pictures
from the past can I just like act like
it's my Instagram from a year ago and
just like every
a posted in a picture so of all the
pictures I've been taking private no
let's pick the best question of the
remaining questions I think you probably
have a better one than I have here
nothing against this particular question
but I'll read them all out loud then the
ones we don't answer people can
conjecture about on using hashtag ear
biscuits and see if they can be answered
without us do you want to do that do
these two I think we can do these two
because they're fun questions I can move
through very quickly so we're skipping
Ryan or Donna's if you were on Amazing
Race would you take the lead
why are you gonna read a question I just
told you that's what I was gonna do and
I asked you should do that well of
course you should you didn't say
anything it's a great question yeah I
win okay go to the next question
it wasn't who would win it would who was
who would take the lead I would drive
you would drive I get carsick yeah and
we would wreck you know even in a cab I
would drive look at us answering it
Hannah asks well or should I this isn't
just Hannah this is Half Moon emoji
Hannah full Sun symbol or the full
spectrum there what's your favorite
texture I love this question to you
what's your favourite texture is gummy a
texture it may be a good texture in your
mouth but what about light on your hands
in my hands everywhere in my hands on my
body in my mouth gummy things do
something for me like a very large gummy
bear I'd I would sleep next to one of
those you know it's not my soul mate or
anything but I the ideal wife on one
side blah becoming on the other taking a
lot just a good large gummy just a hunk
of gummy and just putting it on my cheek
and then taking a bite out of it then
put it back on my cheek and then rubbing
it with my fingers I would love the idea
of all this with gummy come sticky that
is a bad texture for me
yeah but stickiness stick he's not a
texture sticky's a side effect of this
particular thing that has the texture
that I love
stickies and I reckon texting you know
what you can get a you can get a gummy
bear that doesn't have stickiness yeah
you take the sugar out of it the gelatin
doesn't have any sticky and do not eat
those without the sugar it would be a
horrible it would be a horrible
experience but the texture would be
great
I'd love to just have a mask that was
shaped just like my mask that I could
just put my face into every day are you
talking about like hair mask gummy
buoyancy not buoyancy but bounciness in
a little sorceress are you talking about
like that unwed jell-o unwed jello are
you talking about the fruit snacks that
your mom used to buy that we're not the
hardened ones but the real one of those
the Welch's are they Welch they were
shaped like grapes and cherries oh wow
if I could just have a bed made out of I
was watering man you see you'd sweat and
it all gets sticky yeah I'd have
somebody to remake it every night and
this is a no dream world where I have
unlimited access to people who just
generate gummy things for me the whole
house will be gummy the furniture would
be going you owe me a tenner but gummy
steering-wheel I'd eat it I'd use it
this is the world I want to live in
that's what I'm gonna do if you die I
just answered the question I'm gonna
create a gummy world that I live in I
thought my favorite texture with gummy
mancom probably the gummy man net
because I'm sure that that's taken the
gummy man dotnet th ate the gummy man I
thought my favorite texture was the
first thing I thought of was Jade's fur
that's sweet but when you started
talking about gummy I realized there's a
superior texture and I can't place where
I've experienced it specifically but let
me describe it to you and please help me
remember where this has been experienced
because I've been it's like the opening
scene of like the the drama where
they're so in love and then they're
separated by war and distance and
glaciers and they're spinning the whole
movie trying will they reunite and when
one of them has memory loss
that you there's a it's like a cushiony
thing that it's like it's got a vinyl
like a really supple vinyl over a
cushion that when you push on push in on
it and then you take your hands away it
stays the same for a second and then it
slowly started to come back memory foam
its original shape like memory foam but
it's got a it's got a plastic key film
over it
Jakob saying a wrist rest on Mouse yeah
that's more like gut that's good no
that's all gummy yeah that this this is
something it's all of that - I think
it's a certain type of neck pillow that
is cold to the touch and then it's
plasticky but it's a very supple
suppleness to it and it mushes in and
then when you remove your hands it's
slowly it's the type of memory foam
inside of this thing that is not that's
better than memory foam because that's
my favorite texture so you're saying
that I she's almost like a stress ball a
memory foam bed some in them all my life
IRD sleeping it's got a latex covering
over it it's like a it's like a stress
ball there's a certain type of stress
ball that does this but I've experienced
in a bigger way but for a fact it is
absolutely in a stress ball that's like
got a vinyl supple vinyl on the outside
supple vinyl that's links favorite
texture last question Ryan Morris asks
what is the oldest object that you use
on a daily basis that's an interesting
question
oldest object oldest objects Ingle day
there's only a few things I come in
contact with every single day I'm yeah I
can I know what it is well give me yours
because I'm I'm at a loss I'm kind of
stepping through my day but I actually
have a guess of what yours might be okay
I guess it your permanent retainer I
don't use it every day what it's
permanent it's stuck in your mouth
forever what do you mean you don't use
it every day I took that out there oh
you did the dinner it came loose and the
dish took it out that's what I'm about
and tell me my bottom teeth are crooked
now she didn't tell me she was gone yeah
yeah I actually have a No
retainer that I don't wear that's why my
bottom teeth are crooked well I'm a
little I just can't believe you didn't
tell me that well then that was removed
that would be the filling and filling of
course not something that's my ring I'm
not counting that oh you're not like an
object to use if that's not on your
person because I have a couple of
sealants that my Nana snuck into the
dentist office over the weekend what
you're getting very very technical yeah
I'm being honest I've got sealants that
that in fact last time I went to the
dentist he was like your sealants are
still intact
from when you were a kid mine too yeah
my Nana worked for the dentist but she
was not a dentist and then she would
sneak me in on the weekend and give me
things like sealants because she just
she was a dental assistant yeah she did
all the dentists things soul from the
dumbest well who incidentally was your
father-in-law yep it she did assault she
stole from him I mean oh you owe me I'm
sure family stole from my family I'm
sure she told him and it didn't matter
he didn't care now so okay if you see
glints or fillings the ring
I've been real asses I don't want to
think you're frustrated because I was
right now the thing you're gonna tell me
is not as old no no no I'm saying an
object that you come in contact with the
news like for you it might be your
glasses oh like because I feel like the
ring and the glide but things that you
wear yeah Tiffany we can go outside of
the box but I'm taking something that I
come in contact with every single day
for a moment in time and I keep coming
back to it every single give me it let
me can I guess it has to do with my
mouth so this is in the bathroom mm-hmm
your toothbrush is the oldest thing you
come in contact no clothes I know what
it is what you still have one of those
frickin tongue brushes I have the Aurora
brush tongue brush and it has not lost
any of us about fish I mean they
sponsored our videos seven years ago I
don't know it literally says on the
packaging you're supposed to replace it
every year their whole business model is
based on the fact that you can't keep
for that long they made them so well
that I've looked at this thing a million
times and there's absolutely no
degradation on any part of it you know
watch it every single time I use it it
can't autoclave it man
you don't know how clean it is we wash
it you rinse it no but did you think you
but you say you wash it my own soap run
over your feet that doesn't count as
wash you can't reinfect yourself with a
virus or bacteria that you already have
but what about the stuff floating and
landing on it
there's nothing floating and landing on
it from your we've been through this
well yeah but your toothbrush is the
same thing your toothbrush is got crap
all over it you just replace your
toothbrush every single day and take it
out of a sterilized sealed package if
you wanted to avoid those germs I do but
to me I think the thing that I come in
contact with besides my ring and my
fillings and my sealants every single
day that check check is my tongue brush
and it's so old it's seven years old I
get I I got rid of mine not more than a
year ago though so I kept mine for a
long time - and you got rid of it now
because it quit working you got rid of
it why just because I stopped you is you
were like it's you don't you just um
brush me why don't I brush with the
brush again and I'll use them the brush
doesn't work as well I know I mean or
brush is no longer a sponsor of anything
that we do are they are they still
around I don't even know all right but
they had a saying that was a saying it
was a slogan ninety percent or it was
just a fact 90% of bad breath is caused
by a dirty tongue and I wholehearted
around still wholeheartedly believe that
or a brush come back to us you should be
brushing your frickin tongue we need we
need to you guys be founding sponsors of
our pocket ears well I don't know what
that means we'll call you that
there's absolutely no excuse for nine
months a bad bruh say no such a pity
save the ad copy for when we've got the
deal here frickin tongue and then you
and rinse with 50 percent hydrogen
peroxide 50% water gargle with that crap
once a month they'll never have bad
breath I mean I have just saved your
life the oldest object for me I just
figured it out is it's got to be a
t-shirt like I had a every day though
until until we until three years ago
every day but a lot oh but you had that
one that you slept in you know math
Olympia
tshirt I got when I was in I think sixth
grade and I wore it up until three years
ago to sleep in every night yeah slept
in it because you wanted to feel like a
math champion every night yep to balance
to balance my jock ashiness oh gosh
I didn't say jock itch nests I just want
to make sure that can't yeah I knew what
you meant but you don't have that
anymore you'll have your frickin tongue
brush if you don't have you don't have
your frickin retainer I feel so betrayed
you haven't noticed my teeth are getting
crooked I haven't seen your teeth in
five years yeah that's why I don't care
because you can't see my teeth right my
teeth could be any color you can't see
him my mouth is covered by my lips my
teeth are covered by my lips and then my
mustache does the trick as well right
total you don't need to use that a total
tooth coverage total tooth coverage yeah
I'm just gonna quit caring for my
alright oral hygiene altogether because
it doesn't matter speaking of total
tooth coverage you know that we will
totally cover your teeth in here
biscuits anytime you podcast it up with
us you can count on this every week to
do this every week every week will come
back at you ears will come back at you
ears just be ready
[Music]